and my camera
ah we go
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
for babur and mid-suffolk district
councils i'm
councillor alastair mccraw and i will be
chairing the meeting today
can i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
could members please ensure that and
anybody else can please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
and that you do not interrupt other
speakers i'll add that if we have
bandwidth issues at any point it may be
necessary
for non-speakers to turn their cameras
off we'll deal with that when it happens
if you're attending to the meeting to
speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
can i ask you to ensure that mobile
phones are on silent or switched off
and i'd like to remind everyone that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential and
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
so if i can make some introductions we
have officers attending today
these are cassandra clements the
assistant director for environment
and commercial partnerships kathy
obertan
interim corporate manager for
environment and commercial partnerships
our guests attending the meeting are
colin taylor
the managing director for cgt consulting
limited
and mark ms the managing director for
mark
m's consulting we also have in
attendance cabinet members
councillor elizabeth malvisi who is the
bayborough cabinet member for
environment and commercial partnerships
um and i believe councillor jessica
fleming
the mid-suffolk cabinet member for
environment and commercial partnerships
is expected to be in attendance but may
not be here right yet now
so if i can move to the agenda uh we
have apologies for absence and
substitutions as the first item on the
agenda
i'll ask the government's officer to
call the roll call for the
members present thank you chair
um i will call your name and can you
please reply with pl
present please um councillor john dawson
president council jane gould
president we've received apologies from
councillor grandin and councillor
mayberry is substituting councillor
mayberry
mclaren present council
osborne present
and we moved to mid suffolk district
council we have received apologies from
councillor terence carter
and councillor james caston um
councillor hattingham
present councilor john madison
president
and chair i need to add that counselor
john madison is substituting for
councillor carter
thank you very much and now we need to
receive declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare
okay in that case we'll move on to jos
1937
which is the confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee
held on the 20th of july this is the
gender item
three uh members have had a chance to
look through these minutes
um can i ask if there are any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
okay could i have a proposal then that
those minutes be uh
accepted upper pace
uh councillor osborne
uh okay i have councillor hattingham's
hand raised so that came up first so
we'll take a second
from councillor hattingham uh proposed
and seconded
um now we are going to be testing out a
system
not prior previously used uh in a public
meeting
but we will also uh by a general
agreement
make this a recorded vote assuming that
three members
uh can declare they would like it to be
so
i would be one of those members i would
propose that it be a recorded vote
and i would to chair okay that's who was
that
the council of welling council of wellam
and i have councillor hattingham's hand
raised as well
so that's the three members required for
recorded vote
we will be using the recorded vote
system
on the modern gov app which all members
have had access and training to
should any member have any difficulties
with that
we will take a manual vote
uh by a a show of hand if they have been
not been unable to vote
we will need obviously to be certain
that that is the case
but the first team can you please press
the plus button
on your modern gov system and you will
see
an attendance voting button
and you go to attendance first
more than 200 people have been told make
sure
to make sure that your name is
highlighted
in green i believe that councillor
dawson
has not done so as yet but because this
was done in the pre-meeting we held
before this
i know no i haven't i'm afraid okay do
you have modern gov available to you
counselor dawson
no okay councillor dawson in that
instance we would take your vote
um as um manually as it were
so when we reach that point you'll be
asked if you wish to vote for
against or abstain or any other option
that might be used
okay so all other members if you press
the voting button
you will now see that then highlighted
in blue
on the page is a line to confirm the
minutes from the meeting on the 20th of
july
2020 that's been proposed and seconded
and you are being asked to click on that
line and record your vote
in the buck box which allows you to go
for against
abstain or a conflict of interests um
conflict of interest in this instance
would seem to be moot but
for against or abstain please please
vote now
and then confirm your vote and it will
be recorded you're unable to change that
vote once it's been made
and the governance officer will inform
us when all voting is complete
yes chairman all voting is complete and
i can confirm we have seven
votes four uh and three abstentions
and then i need to ask for counsel
dawson for her vote please
i'm four so that's eight votes four
and three and three abstentions chair
so the vote is carried thank you very
much that's great
great well done nice little test for
everybody
those minutes have been confirmed and
will be signed the next
practicable opportunity and i have
something strange going on
on my computer system so i will just ask
you
to bear with me a moment while i try and
something has strange has come up on my
screen it seems to be a reminder
for the meeting which i'm currently in
great
sure sorry i believe uh one of the
attendees is sharing their screen by
accident
okay can that be changed and sorted i
think it's just a minor point
item four on the agenda is to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
non-received chair thank you very much
item five questions by the public
non-received
and item six questions by councillors
non-received chair thank you very much
we've now moved to agenda item
seven which is the main topic on today's
agenda
i really would like it if we could just
get rid of this uh
reminder because of the shared screen
sorry
it's me jim and i'm struggling to get
rid of it i do apologize
it just popped up on the screen okay i
think if you go to the three little
buttons
in the center of your bar you should
find an option to
share screen there and be able to take
it off there am i correct
chair yes there should be it's like a
little square with an arrow
on and
councillor hadingham has something to
say i don't know if that's relevant to
it
um my screen says that sue ayers is
sharing her screen
okay fine councillor ayers could you
have a look
and see if you go to your central
buttons and
clear this this box it would be very
helpful
i don't know if that is the place is it
oh it's the it's the
net block next to the three little dots
it's the um arrow
pointing up it's a share tray and i
believe that councillor aires thank you
very much councillor ayers hopefully we
can now return
to that's better we can all see the
whites of each other's eyes
as it were okay
item seven on the agenda is uh
jos 1938 or mc1938 i'm not sure which to
be honest i think it's probably both
which is the future delivery model for
public realm
i would like to ask cassandra clements
the assistant director
for environment and commercial
partnership to introduce this report jos
1938
future delivery model for public realm
over to you cassandra
good afternoon sharon thank you for the
introductions to both myself and my
guests and and thank you to the joint
committee for inviting us here today
to talk about the future delivery model
for public realm
and so i'm pleased to put this report in
front of you today
as the report that is due to go to
cabinet
later this month and to hear your
thoughts and questions on this
so um as you are aware it's quite a
lengthy document so i'm going to attempt
to summarize that for you
and we'll probably get some help from my
colleagues as well
but this report if i start with where
this came from
so um i've been imposed for just over a
year now
and public realm is clearly within my
responsibility and
and next year the baba district council
contract with id verdi is due to
to finish and that has got to the end of
all possible extensions and so a
decision must be made by
vapor district council on what they
would like to do going forward
it seemed a good opportunity given that
these contracts are always quite
long and this one nearly 15 years in its
entirety
to take a look at the service to look at
what developments that we would like to
make as a council
but also the opportunity as to whether
baber district council or mid-suffolk
district council would like to
work together under the same management
agreement for public role
as they do with many other services
across the councils
and so in june of this year an options
appraisal was undertaken
with my colleagues colin taylor and mark
ms
and to look at what the opportunities
are
moving forward you'll see within the
report and i understand
for consideration today are four options
so there are option one which is to
continue
continue to deliver the service as is
and so this means that baby district
council would need to tender a new
contract for the public realm service
option two is to bring the currently
outsourced service for weber in-house
and to join together with
mid-suffolk district council in-house
public realm service
option three is to look at putting both
services together
and outsource them and so a tender
process would take place
and option four was looking at
establishing a trading company
in which the councils would be able to
put their public realm services
into um you will see in the report that
there is an officer recommendation
within that
however um as you will know this
decision has not taken place and all
four options are still available to the
councils to decide
in looking at the uh the evidence that
was in the options appraisal
with my colleagues and with other
officers
the recommendation is to move forward
with option two
which is to bring the baby district
contract in-house
and join together with mid-suffolk the
reasons around that are
are within the report but there are a
number of
benefits to that which is why officers
are suggesting it
and that is absolutely around
performance
around management around the financial
structures
and around service development which is
an area that i feel has been lacking
um for for some time in public realm
and so today in front of you you have um
a lot of information i know
um but essentially i would like to
talk to a committee today and be able to
help you answer questions around
um understanding those options uh what
you feel are
the pros and cons around those and any
support that as offices we can give you
to help inform cabinet uh is why we're
here today
um i hope that's a good summary for you
councillor mccraw and i'll hand back
over to you now
well i'm fairly sure we can pick you up
on specifics of this 152-page report
actually
to be fair it's only about 132. uh the
rest was taken up with the rest of our
bump
however uh it is a a complete and
extensive report and
i think it's reasonable to say all four
cases have been properly examined
uh i think it's very useful to point out
that we have the advantage
of two separate service supplies
in place at the moment and therefore
members of
both these committees will have
experience of of of two of the options
will in fact covering three
of the options so we are able to speak
directly
and relevantly to the subject so what
i'd like to ask is for members to
now ask their questions on the report
and on the presentation i'll ask you to
keep this as possible
wide as possible because we don't want
to get into the point where we have to
go
into a private closed session because
we're discussing financial matters
this could after all involve possible
outsourcing
so we'd be required to tender we cannot
reveal uh
the proprietary information that might
have an effect upon that
and also there are employment
considerations that we must
include so i'll ask each member in turn
and we'll start off with councillor
lavinia hadingham
any questions councillor i can come back
to anybody if they're not quite ready
however
your microphone doesn't appear to be on
council hattingham
thank you um i just want to say i'm
excellent report cassie very thorough
and um you know basically midsuffoca are
sorted so i'm very happy
i haven't got any questions i just want
to say well done fantastic report
perhaps you'll be able to offer some
observations on how mid-suffolk might be
sorted uh a
point of debate councillor mary mclaren
thank you chair um at this part of the
meeting
um i just want to recommend the officers
uh on their report a well-executed
report
lots of good detail but at the moment i
don't have any questions thank you
thank you councillor muller dave muller
thank
you chair again an excellent report but
i have no questions at this time thank
you
okay councillor adrian osborne
thank you mr chairman yes um i i concur
with
exactly what's been uh said by the other
councillors
uh casa is an excellent uh in-depth
report and i think you've gone through
every
every possible position there are
questions obviously but
uh if there are uh option then i'll
speak to them on on that occasion thank
you
thank you very much councillor osborne
councillor keith scarf
thank you chair yeah just just one it
mentions in the report
um the arboricultural works that are
carried out by
public realm at the moment um in in in
that sense it's
um minor uh tree works are carried out
by ourselves
and major tree works are carried out by
a contractor
um i wonder if we could give some
thought to
the possibility with whatever option we
decide to recommend to the cabinet
to look at the arbor cultural works
because although it's um
a very expensive thing to set up it
could be quite useful
for uh our public partners that we
intend to work with
more closely and would give us perhaps a
different
route into uh some of the parish
councils and uh
public bodies yep i think that's an
excellent point councillor scuff in fact
most of us with work uh
or associations with parish councils are
only too aware of the
the difficulties involving trees uh
councillor keith wellam
thank you chair yeah again yes i'd like
to say it's an excellent report
just a couple of i don't know whether
they're questions or comments but
um it just seems to me that the service
wasn't developed in the way that it
could have been developed but i wondered
if that was hampered
by one manager
attempting to develop to run
a service in two different in two
in two different um districts by two
different methods
uh do you think that part of that is
because there were two different methods
of
of running the service and the other
the other point is that whichever option
we adopt i think the quantitative side
of the service is extremely important
but it's also important that residents
and members
are able to contact either the client
or to contact the client in some way
and for appropriate action to be taken
okay taking those as questions uh cass
could you uh comment on that yes of
course so
um around the two models um i i
genuinely believe that a single manager
would be perfectly capable of running
two models and outsourced underneath
sourced um i think what i found when i
joined the organization
were some inefficient management
processes and unfortunately that did
lead to
a lack of contract management within the
baby district council contract um
i also think that that is possibly the
reason why
development uh was not as strong as it
should have been
moving forward with with whichever
option
is taken an absolute priority for me
is that we have um efficient
uh and appropriate management uh
processes
in place for staff for finance and for
development
and i think um even if that were to stay
as two models if we stayed
with option one um i think the right
manager would be able to do that
perfectly well
okay and the um other point on
arboricultural you think you think that
that's something that is possible for
future development
yes apologies so uh on on our cultural
absolutely there are there are a couple
of areas of development that i'd like to
look for
in the first instance um we want to look
at
ensuring we get inspect the inspection
regime
as as hot as we possibly can so that
would be my first instinct
my second is then to move on to what
we're able to offer
to um district and the parish sorry to
parish and town
councils so absolutely i think that
could extend to works and i think that
could extend to
inspections my first priority will be
making sure that we deliver the public
realm service that we need to
for the two districts and once we're
comfortable with that
that we move on to what we can offer
other people that might fall into the
sort of luxury category
when we can if you can follow yes okay
councilor matheson you have your hand
raised but i was going to ask you to
have a question
now if you wish um yes thank you
the um that i think on the councillor
wellam scarce point um i was a bit
concerned that
in the list in the purpose of the report
the very beginning
um that um our borrowed culture trees
were not actually mentioned
in the um um the delivery of the
following services i think that
probably all members would agree that um
the the tree aspect is quite a
significant part so i think that's just
a little
an anomaly and i think the other thing i
did want to ask um the
officers is that the
the consultant's report that page 47
i think that's page 47 of our papers
um does go into quite a bit of detail
about the
gaps in information that they were able
to obtain
and um so i wonder whether you might
like to comment on that
um on their observations which i've got
in front of me and i'll try and get them
i recall the section it's a lengthy it's
a it's a lengthy report but yeah i can
recall
seeing that cassandra
yes of course so um so in terms of why a
borah culture was left off the purpose
of the report
that is specifically because it's not
undertaken by id
birdie and so we were talking about um
what is currently in the i diverted
contract with baby district council
we do have an aborticultural team of uh
two
david pizzi and andrew graham that work
across
both of the districts and so
um that essentially is already a shared
service it's within public realm
but it's not within the grounds
maintenance or the street maintenance
which is currently out to contract for
weber so that's why it's not in the
purpose of the report but i absolutely
agree with you councillor madison
uh it's a high priority for both
councils without doubt
um so i'm just moving to page 47 of the
report if you'll bear with me a second
role i'll just
um read that particular bit um although
i
i do have mark and colin with me who may
be able to jump in
the review process and describes the
project uh taking place from the 22nd of
april
um i think this was a you said about a
lack of data available
in certain parts count councillor
matheson
yes they they um yeah i just wondered
you know why why they've
you know they they felt the need to say
that
you know it would that it was it must
have been quite an extensive gap
i see yes indeed so so um
in terms of uh predominantly what is
listed on this report is
i alluded to earlier some of the
management systems that i felt were
not up to scratch and essentially the
gaps that the consultants have included
in this
are are the specifics of those and so
whilst work is undertaken
um it often was not recorded
properly and therefore is a is a data
gap in
in its hard sense although in a soft
sense anecdotally was available
um one of the things that clearly i want
to put right
since we have a two of the consultants
present here
i don't know if they want to address us
colin taylor and mark m's who are both
part of that review process
uh i do recall though from a
conversation i held some years ago
about the difficulties of constructing a
database for every tree in
in babylon with suffolk and i'm not
joking that conversation was genuinely
held
so i don't know if mark and colin would
like to have any input at this point
um yeah yeah happy chair just to say a
few words on that um
as well as the data that we highlighted
there that we
we couldn't find that it wasn't didn't
have a material impact on producing the
report at all
in appendix one on page 83 um
you're about to see the data that was
considered so there is quite an
extensive list there of information that
was
um looked at and we highlighted those
bits there
and there was i think it's fair to say
there was some
transition and change going on in the
management team at the time
obviously we would have we were dealing
with uh meetings of our teams etcetera
it would have been nice to get going to
the office and meet people at the time
but
we just felt that we should highlight a
few bits and pieces there that
um would be additional of additional
benefit um for the council to look at in
the future really
if i could add to that i don't know mark
sorry if colin has something else to say
as well apologies colin you go ahead
just gonna say the other important thing
to recognize about page 47 is that sits
in the
initial report we did the options
appraisal
and some of that information we were
able to build upon having identified it
it was missing into the business case we
were able to dig a bit deeper and fill
some of those gaps
although cassandra said some of them in
reality
still exist um as a sort of you know
hard data
the important point i suppose i'd like
to ask both of you john
just on your point to john just wanted
to add in this point is i
hadn't appreciated the interesting point
about the
um the the tree service was actually
across the two districts
um i i did very much look at the both
the report and particularly the
um the consultants report as
you know as a description of the whole
of public realms
operations so um and i i think the
um so i now i understand that that's
helpful but i think i think
there is so much there that um that may
you know it ought to be carried forward
as a description of the whole of public
realm
um as a future working document for the
department really
i was going to say councilor matheson
just to answer your question it might be
simply summed up was that was there
sufficient
data for you to be able to draw the
conclusions
and be confident in the conclusions you
drew
yeah i i i'm i'm comfortable with with
that i
thought it was it was it was useful to
see that set out sure
i was just thinking did the consultants
feel they had sufficient data
um you know that's the key i think i was
trying to bring out here
i think on on balance we did i mean i i
think if you look at the
as mark alluded to the list of data we
did have
um it was it was extensive and we had
very very
solid cooperation from um
across the councils and
i i think if we if we felt we hadn't got
the information in sufficient
um detail and quantity we would have
highlighted that
right we're very happy that everything
we came up we
put in our report supportable okay uh
next
member i have on my list is councillor
casten who i know is not present
is anybody substituting for councillor
casting today
uh no chair there's no substitution for
countless casters in that case uh
councillor dawson
uh do you have any any question to ask
yeah i was just
the one thing that's slightly bothering
me which i wasn't quite getting answers
is
this business about where we're taking
on large areas
is back to the trees where we're taking
on large areas
on large um sites such as persimmons
where they're paying
um where they're paying us a fee
where where we'll be doing all the
cutting of the hedges the trees etc
and these are very small sums going
forward
um you know like 20 000 i don't know
whatever it is for
a number of years i'm just sort of
wondering whether that's been taken into
account
because my slight concern is that
we might have a lot of large projects
mid-suffolk may
not or it could be vice versa
does this mean that we might be able to
dip into their pot
might they be able to dip into our pot
or is there a very specific
one each capsule
i think i think anybody's ever had any
handling dealing with section 106
has found that developers are very
unhappy about any prospect of somebody's
pot being
dealt dipped into but there's a point i
mean planning obviously
will have an impact but does it have a
significant impact cassandra
so um what we are developing alongside
this
uh my colleague emily atac is currently
developing the
asset strategy and that will contain
uh our policy around adoption of london
and what that entails
so exactly that if there are further
burdens to the council moving forward be
that grass cutting hedges trees
uh what exactly that means to us so
clearly
if we do take on any land that has an
effect on public realm
it will be my myself and my team's
responsibility to ensure that we
request the the correct amount of
section 106
clearly that's only ever for a term but
what um what i want to get in place
really rigorously is the correct
drawdown per year
of what that cost so we can clearly see
how long that commuted sum will last the
public realm service
and that we we draw on that adequately
to cover the service provision
so i can say very sorry if i could just
um
i understand all that but i would
obviously if i may
uh it was more the fact that on the or
on on things we've already done
or we've already agreed lump sums um
it's what's becoming very evident is
there is not enough money
and that you can't do it so in the event
next year
we start to take all this in house
are these two councils are they going to
have
separate budgets and is there a
guarantee
with existing um existing
contracts that we take on from these
companies like mccarthy and stone
persimmon
that the works will be done i'm just not
clear from what i i'm reading here
is that the two councils if we come
together does that mean our budget
becomes one or are we still
separate i see okay sure
so you have completely separate budgets
and they cannot be used in each district
they cannot be merged they are
absolutely two separate accounts and so
what we can't do
is use any of the baby budget to pay a
mid suffolk or any of the mid-suffolk
budget to pay for work in baber
what you will be able to do which i do
see is an advantage is
uh with your staff members so if there
are um
there is a bigger staff team to to call
upon
um there can be a flexible approach to
if there are peaks and troughs within
the districts to support
so on the staff level absolutely there
can be but on the budget level
you absolutely cannot and going forward
then
with existing contracts that we've taken
on and i'm sure
mid suffolk have the same from some of
these large
companies um what is going to be the
commitment then
i mean i can just give you an example
we've got the mccarthy and stone
you know and they haven't done any of
these trees and this is going to be a
huge cost and it seems environment of
taking it on
and i'm almost sure they're going to say
oh we can't do it
so does this fall into the planning or
does it fall
will it be falling into our your area
i'm not so um
[Music]
i'm confused whether we've taken it on
or not from that but if we if we have
had something that we've already taken
on
um then it would fall into the public
realm team uh
to to do the work in that what i would
say is what need what really needs to
happen
um even for land that we've agreed but
not yet taken on perhaps and it's it's
in the in the suit at the near future um
that we need to be really robust with
developers that we don't take on
land that isn't too standard so quite
often
land deteriorates prior to transfer yes
and and councils not just our councils
other councils
quite often end up getting pushed into
taking that land too
early because they don't necessarily
have the resource to to
argue the point of the developer and i'm
quite strong on that point we should not
be taken on land that is not up to
standard when it gets transferred over
to us
so that should minimise the financial
risk
yep can i just intervene here briefly
because effectively
cass we're considering four separate
models is there any functional
difference between which model
in this instance it doesn't really seem
to make a great deal of difference which
model we adopt
the that effect will exist i have one in
my own ward
but effectively i don't see that this
affects the choice of model
i take councillor dawson's point it's a
very good one and it's a long-term
concern but obviously it covers a
different area and i think it's outside
the remit of this discussion
we're looking at the foreign chair sorry
to interrupt
the only thing i would say is option one
so if they were to retender and this
would
be outsourced you'd have a schedule of
rates with the contractor
so if land came to us uh out of standard
and required
extra work than what was originally
understood
it would end up costing the council more
to bring that up to standards
because we would be outside contract so
effectively that would require that
would indicate
a preference for an option where we have
more control
and could be as flexible as possible
which would seem to
indicate options two or four that's
correct
okay that's great that's really been
useful thank you very much councillor
dawson
i have uh next on the list uh councillor
gould jangled
yes thank you hand up real um sorry
counselor osborne i will come back to
you i think we've uh we had your
question earlier did we not
you you passed on it but i will come
back to those members who wish to ask
questions at the end
nobody will be left out counsellor gould
um thank you for the report um cassandra
very full as as other members have said
i'm a bit confused
if we've got separate budgets and we can
so we can't have flexibility over
budgets crossing over
but we can have flexibility over staff
crossing over
surely staffing costs come out of the
budget so
how does that work sure so the way that
works is that there is an overall
management agreement between the two
councils
and that's something that's reviewed
every year i'm sure i now have my
colleague john snell on here
that uh may know more about this for me
but as i understand that is reviewed
every year and we are
a portion a percentage of the team as to
which council pays what so here's what
they it cost in its entirety
so is it 50 50 some will be 60 40.
and there are very clear formulas as to
how we work out so for instance in
housing it will be on the number of
houses within
each district so the budgets are
separate but that is what dictates what
goes into those
core budgets such as salary lines would
that be
an internal charging system that's
correct yeah
okay so charges and recharges anything
else councillor gold
no thank you thank you very much
councillor mabry and then we'll come
back to councillors osborne and
matterson
councillor mayberry thank you thank you
very much mr chairman
um i i do have a few uh questions and
and comments and
um if um cassandra
needs me to stop between each one that's
absolutely fine
my biggest concern with this with
option two is the
reliance on bringing things into house
and the huge issues that we had when we
did this with bm
bms building services um which
turned into a nightmare and a financial
black hole
that is my first concern um my second
is um under 1.1
you're talking about the countryside and
the services that you provide
there is nothing there that mentions dog
bins
now if somebody is walking their dog
along a footpath
they still have to collect after their
dog
and it is put in the bin and there are
plenty of dog bins on footpaths
so that is missing and i'm i wonder if
that's an oversight
or whether that is because you're not
going to do it anymore
did you wish to answer those two first
yeah
i think any parish councillor definitely
wants to know about dog bins
90 of our time yeah that's very true
so um on the first point there
councillor maybe thank you for those
uh with bnbs um what we have been able
to do there
is um use that as a lessons learned
um opportunity so clearly there were
um issues when that happened and the the
service have done a lot of work i know
uh under giving fisk the assistant
director
to to um get the service to where it is
now and there are still further
developments that he wants to make what
it gives us the opportunity to do is
make sure that we don't make
those mistakes we make sure we learn
from it um and
both mark and colin who are in the room
with me uh
understand what happened previously and
so when it comes to whichever option we
agree to go forward a very very clear
plan needs to be brought together with
adequate resources and adequate
management processes
to make sure that we do not repeat
previous mistakes or make new ones at
that point
as as recommended i might point out by
this very scrutiny committee
and with our own experience of examining
bnbs
councillor maybe did you have anything
else um well the dog bins
the third bullet down talks about street
scene and within there is emptying
litter and dog bins
street scene to my
councillor dawson was was talking about
um taking on parcels of land et cetera
on developments uh i do remember that
um council and previous
cabinet did decide
that management companies would be
encouraged to take on any areas
of open space on development
and i hope that is going to be
continued um further to that
if i can talk about um trees
trees are very expensive um as soon
as soon as there is an issue with a tree
particularly if it's
a large tree and a large bowel that say
comes off
of a tree which happens in dry weather
um the clear up is very costly and
we should remember that there was also
the opportunity for parish councils
to have devolved to them their open
spaces
and they take control um this is
something
under asset transfer that i i
particularly in particular have been
asking for ages
and i hope that that will still continue
and further on about trees
unfortunately in my experience with
trees
um and the team that we have
yes the trees may be inspected but
unfortunately the tree work
does not follow on and i have specific
um instances that i can relate to you on
another occasion cass
and that does worry me enormously
when i am sent an email that confirms
work has been done
i visit hasn't been done email goes back
it's been done and it goes on like this
for six months until they decide
oh no it hasn't been done and it really
really worries me
about the tree aspect in the future for
public um for public realm um
i think that is it at the moment
so thank you i think your points
councillor maybe really do come back to
this
central question which we're here to
examine today is which model would best
serve the concerns you've just raised
and
or if there is any difference between
the models which model puts us
in the best position to do the things
that both you councillor dawson and a
variety of other people have mentioned
councillor matheson you have your hand
raised
thank you chair yes um just to
point out to members generally there's
there's a useful discussion of the
commuted sum problem
on page 55 um and
and i agree with the chair that the
um that isn't is is peripheral
or has no no relevance probably at all
to
to the discussion about the options and
i'm
i think i'm increasingly anxious that we
um
the chair is right to focus on what
makes a difference
in choosing the best option yeah um but
at the same time
that we somewhere towards the end of the
meeting we also um
round up some of the incredibly useful
work that's been done
for us and and reference it up to the to
the um
cabinets as a probably an additional
couple of
two or three recommendations possibly
perhaps we'll leave that one together
i think i think that really comes up
after debate um has
any other member got any other question
before i ask for any attending members
outside the
committees if they wish to speak
councillor wellam you wish to speak
or ask a question uh yes please yeah
thank you thank you chair
um i i believe there must be a
short-term need for additional resources
um
and the other thing is how accurately
can we uh
estimate the the setup costs including
the staff costs
and how would they be a portion between
the two authorities
um at present or as we move forward
there's three operations are going to be
carried on concurrently
there's the in-house business as usual
um
that's on mid-suffolk there's a contract
supervision and wind down of that
contract in
in babur and then there's the need to
set up a new arrangement
um because that won't just be the
mid-suffolk that won't be the
the same arrangement it'll have to be a
new arrangement i guess
so i guess there there is
a need for additional resources but from
a parochial point of view i
i feel it's very important that the
in-house
mid-suffolk operations don't suffer
whichever whichever way whichever way we
go forward
um uh so um
yeah we need to be building on a
successful
um organization i think we're
approaching the point of debate ernest
you have a question
here uh
well the question is um
have you assessed what additional
resources will be needed
and are they going to be made available
absolutely okay thank you councillor
william yes so on uh the subject of
resources
uh this will need a full project team to
be uh
starting immediately after the cabinet
decision
no matter what option goes forward and
so that
that um project team thank you pardon
is from across the organization and not
just from within the public realm
service so
there are um colleagues from finance
from
hr from communications and from our
project management office to name just a
few
as well as the colleagues within public
realm that will form
a project management group that i will
be sponsoring myself and
so those resources initially have
already been
um have already been scoped and of
course
uh there is the further opportunity if
necessary
uh with my colleagues in the room with
colin and mark to have some
external expertise should it be needed
as well so
depending on what option is agreed going
forward depends on
exactly the nuances of that team but i
completely agree
additional resources absolutely
necessary
in addition to that on your second
element there of resource is
um for both councils actually
a really robust um performance
management regime needs to be put in in
this
in this next year so for baber in the
final year of a contract without a doubt
you need that
that um managed carefully to make sure
that standards don't drop
but equally that needs to be managed
carefully in mid-suffolk to make sure
that that is not the service there is
not impacted
clearly from where um from whatever
option goes forward
um that needs to continue until the
options agreed
we can't tell you exactly what that's
going to look like
i think it's worth noting for members
that the transition period
uh is described completely or rather
very fairly completely
across pages 125 129 in the confidential
report
so it is clear this has been considered
so i'd recommend that
for for reading and it's a full process
to
cover the all the way through to the
start of whatever
arrangement we uh recommend now i still
have a couple of hands up counselor
matheson is that hand from previously or
is that a new hand
your microphone is off counselor
matthison
no problem counselor maybe you raised
your hand
um yes i did um this may well run into
the previous question um and also
maybe something that will be discussed
in the private area but just to mention
it now
is my biggest concern is probably
staffing benefits pensions
large vehicles that might be required
definitely councilman definitely in the
private area because we're dealing but
if i
if i raise it now then um it is
recorded as needing an answer i think
absolutely certain it will be attended
too but it's very much going to be in
the confidential section we're talking
about people's jobs and a possible
tender
process so we have to do that properly
if uh anybody got any other questions
before we move on i had myself down but
i think i've said quite enough and i got
most of my questions squeezed in there
anyway
um so he says looking for his uh
crib list we now come to
a matter of debate and i'd just like to
start and ask members as a
starting point if you could compare your
own experience
of public realm as it exists currently
at baber
as it exists at mid suffolk compare
and contrast because as far as i can
tell
that certainly affects option one option
two
and option three since they all
variations on those
the current situation so i would suggest
that members approach it from the point
of view of our own experience
of public realm as it has been delivered
in the past
and then we can start to look towards
the future over to you members
uh raise your hands if you wish to speak
for debate
councillor scarf thank you chair yeah
well my experience since i've been back
on
mid suffolk which is uh just about a
year is that
the service has been very responsive if
you've asked them
uh to do anything um
the only examples where it might not
have been quite so easy is where the
ownership of said hedge or piece of land
or strip of grass
is in is in doubt i have to say though
even in some circumstances there i've
had a very quick response and the work
has been done
very quickly uh you know even if it
might not have been our responsibility
to do it
so i found them to be very responsive uh
to my emails or telephone calls
thank you very much councillor scarf uh
kessler hattingham
a mid-suffolk member your experiences
counselors having a microphone may not
be on
no it's off right thanks i just want to
underline what counselor scarf has just
said i've always found them
excellent you know straight on the ball
especially i want to shout out to dave
pizzi
you know he's always you know very quick
to respond
and um and yeah i just want to say i
think they do a great job
and i've always found them um you know
very you like i say
quick to respond and and very easy to
deal with
thank you very much um and who's next i
have three others but it's not showing
me who they are
so one of those others who've had their
hand raised would like to make
themselves known to me
it's uh councillor wilhelm next chance
that's lowell and thank you very much
henriette thank you chair yeah i mean i
i reiterate what the uh what my
colleagues have said
very quick to respond my only concern is
that they are very very quick to inspect
trees and talk to residents who are
affected by
overhanging trees and so on but the work
sometimes doesn't get done
often doesn't get done or it doesn't get
done to the extent
that they have led those residents to
believe it would be done
so that's my only concern it's over the
amount of work that's done to trees fair
enough
okay uh who's next
counselor muller counselor hattingham
your hand is still raised
councillor muller thank you chair um
well in the stow thorny ward which
predominantly covers cedars park
in in stone market up until the last
year
chris nicholson who are one of the major
um builders
on the estate were responsible for
tidying up the estate and on the whole
they did a really good
job but often where this had failed
trying to get them to do the work was an
absolute nightmare and i know that other
builders also found it quite a nightmare
as well
uh if you try to get hold of them after
the builders moved off the estate
since public realm particular john
buckingham's team have taken over
i have to be full of praise for that
team they've been
absolutely brilliant and i often speak
to john at least once a week
or email him a couple of times a week
and the work is always done promptly
and i've had many um residents who've
written to me in the first place
to pass on their messages of thanks to
john's team for the really excellent
work
they have done so i do i do like the
method with uh keeping the uh
the work in-house chair thank you i'm
hearing positive so far from mid-suffolk
a babe remember now uh counselor
mayberry
yes um thank you um i've already spoken
about tree work that um hasn't
been undertaken one of the biggest
issues that
i have had particularly in my ward
where we've had development over the
last
four five six years has been with the
legal issues
of actually getting the legal team
to transfer the land to whoever it's
supposed to
go to and i hope that in future that
this will be tightened up and it will be
done
quickly and promptly um i still have one
i think that's probably about four years
old
and that's just far too long and it's
i think i think as soon as as soon as
the lawyers become involved we find
things slow down don't we
but it but counsellor it shouldn't
no i shouldn't they are professional
they should be doing their job
you're right and it comes also it
affects the planning issues as well
and transfer of responsibility for areas
i think these are all wider issues
that may be directly outside the remit
except where they
are affected by the model that we are
looking at here
councillor matheson
you hadn't had yes um yes broadly
broadly agreeing with others i think
just picking up a couple of other points
um that that um have have been done well
by the
the team serving mid suffolk which baby
members might
you know know as to making sure that you
know that
they will get the best for that from
their point of view
is is the fly tipping um
successfully turning up and dealing with
those problems
which which has been good and also
um for example
where where um an animal is
unfortunately
um injured or killed um on the roads
um i think above and beyond what one
could reasonably expect i mean to take
to take the the um the animal to the vet
get it read the microchip find the
address
bring the bring the cat bring the cat
back i mean
really that that was that was terrific
and and you know that that i think
that's
to me that's that's about the quality of
the people
that live and work in mid-suffolk
yeah um quite quite literally going
stronger strong argument for the for the
for the option too isn't it thank you
quite literally going the extra mile
councilman
it is yeah no i agree it's about
ownership if i i could add here i've got
my own comment to
throw in as a baby member because i too
found the fly tipping uh
treatment to be very positive um and a
very quick response and a consistently
good response and i think it's
it's very impressive to uh as ward
members
when we are informed of a piece of fly
tipping in our district
and it can be dealt with the same day or
within 24 hours
and i know i find great satisfaction in
that
at the same time other people may have
different experiences
uh but i'm obviously on the a137 which
is a nice straightforward
place to find some places are rather
more remote
and it can be difficult but the one
thing i've noticed
uh from the baber experience of dealing
with a contractor is that there's been a
certain lack of
ownership uh by the contractor since
they are
purely employed on a contractual basis
and also
i'm sorry i didn't quite hear what that
was but uh they
they are um they are um
less less committed uh in the way that
councilor matheson's described than
perhaps
uh people who are actually actively
working for the councils on an in-house
operation
um i think that's an important
observation councillor mayberry
councillor mabry you have your hand
raised
uh your microphone may not be on alistar
yes sorry it stops it all i'm really
sorry i'm going to have to cut out of
this meeting i've got an emergency
that's arrived here i should come back
in do you understand okay um i think
you've heard sufficient of the meeting
uh and i'll take advice from uh
henriette here
but i think i sent you a text i'll send
you a with my
response and i shall try and get back as
soon as i do it as an elderly gentleman
okay
absolutely if you're able to come back
in i would judge that you would be able
to vote
on this matter since you've heard the
majority of the presentation the report
and so i believe that'll be correct
henriette can you confirm that
well generally uh i would say that in
order to make an informed decision you
would have to
be present at the whole committee
meeting to hear the whole argument and
the whole
um yep okay you take your point i wanted
to confirm it
no that's fine you can't quite
understand counselor dawson we all know
what it's like being an award
uh so i'm afraid you won't be able to
vote but you certainly welcome back into
the meeting later
councillor mclaren thank you chad um i'd
just like to
say about um the rural
awards that often they
lack of full support from public realm
means that
the many volunteers we have in our
parishes
often do a lot of that work and i think
that's often how the work is achieved
because people go out on their own
initiative and actually cut hedges down
and whatever
so uh it is quite different i think in
baby
there are there are there are areas of
course in more rural areas where of
course ownership of the land and
responsibility i know
grass cutting for example where uh it's
uncertain as to whether suffolk county
council are cutting the grass
baber district council are cutting the
grass baber district council are cutting
the grass on behalf of suffolk county
council
or the parish council are cutting the
grass or in fact
one or two local residents cut the grass
on their corner
because they have taken a certain amount
of pride and again it's the same with
hedges and growth and we
all deal with this on a daily basis i
think it's and volunteers are
always going to be necessary and i know
of members who carry a pair of secateurs
around with them to deal with the odd
stray bit
and peace uh councillor maybe you have
your hand raised um yes i do thank you
um
i was just going to
really it's more of a question but a
better comment
rather than debating um which follows on
from
councillor mclaren uh that we have lots
and lots of
voluntary litter picking schemes that
happen during the year
um and i hope that these will carry on
because
it gives residents a sense of ownership
and i hope that whatever model is chosen
that we will be able to
uh continue with those can you cover
that cassandra
i certainly can thank you for letting me
come back into the chair um yes
so to cover those points firstly what um
they we already do around the the litter
picks absolutely i want to continue
but um i completely agree with
councillor mclaren in that we have
so many volunteers out there that go off
and
either do small pieces on their own or a
part of a wider group
and litter pick or cut whatever it may
be what i would like to do is to
to develop some support from them i
don't want us to get involved i don't
want us to take credit
you know those people take a lot of
pride in the work that they do
sometimes they just need a little bit of
support so if it means providing them
with a litter picker or collecting
the rubbish for them afterwards whatever
that might be i think as
a district council we should be
supporting that and helping
and i would really like to to make sure
we promote that
and on top of what else people can do so
whether it's working in our countryside
sites
um you know those are particularly green
fingers there are always some small
roles that you can do
yeah and i would really really like to
promote volunteering across the
districts
and to a further point on that my own
parish council in branson
has employed two litter pickers um for
years on end and
uh they provide an excellent service
that village remains clean every so
often though we do an annual litter pick
for those areas that are not so
accessible and in fact we have a
situation where
it could be called fly tipping but
actually it's a local place and it's not
somewhere that public realm can
get to it literally is off the beaten
track
but it's it's a it's an eyesore and we
don't want to let it stay that way
councilor mclaren can i just follow with
the
litter picking i think that's an ideal
moment
um in my ward which is holbrook
harkstead and stutton
our beaches and shoreline
during this lockdown have been
absolutely decimated
with broken bottles litter human
excrement
absolutely dreadful and um
people it's the volunteers really that
have got together
to actually clear that can i ask a
question of the baby members i'm getting
a very clear
steer from the mid suffolk members who
are obviously
happier with the in-house service that
they're provided
than maybe the baby members are with the
contractual service that we're provided
with
and what what are members feeling about
contractual services
and their future which is very much part
of what we're discussing today
i'd like to ask members what their views
on contractual
uh uh contractual approach in other
words options
one and three
any members any thoughts on that
counselor muller
thank you chair yes i know it was
mentioned earlier
about maintenance companies maintaining
the land and again there are several of
these within the stone thorny ward again
and on cedars park but i i do
urge caution because one of the
companies is absolutely appalling
um residents can never get hold of them
either by email or
phone and i've had numerous complaints
and it's just an absolute night
excuse me absolute nightmare so i do
urge
caution and that's why i'm in favor of
the actual
in-house scheme so i got a frog in my
throat
okay so in-house in-house scheme uh
from there and i'm getting that from mid
suffolk as a whole uh councillor
matheson and then there's two others
councillor scarf and one other
councillor
matthison first and then i'll come
together yes thank you yeah i think um
yes yes absolutely um what people are
saying
what i wanted to pick up particularly
there was was what cassandra
had just said about promoting
volunteering and i think
one of the reasons why the in-house
operation is is the best option
is because the the extent to which
public realms work
and various parts of its work we talked
about several of them now
um overlapped so much with the
with the volunteering and with the
community
um and um if
if the public know that that um
you know company a is responsible for
doing these things
then it will be less likely to actually
contribute than than if it knows that
it's
it's our our own their their
own staff that they're paying
directly through us to employ um that
there's a
you know there's a significant
difference and i think this is more
applicable
to to public realm than any other part
of the council
thank you okay thank you very much
councillor matheson uh councillor scarf
then uh councillor osborne and mayberry
thank you chair yeah i mean i was just
going to make the point that i think
if it's in-house it is responsive it is
flexible as a service
far more so than if it's under a
contract a contract
has to be tied up literally every loose
end and if it's not in the contract
you don't get it done by the contractor
and that's fair enough because they've
not put it in the contract or we've not
put it in the contract
um but if you um have a service which is
delivered in-house you have that
ultimate flexibility and responsiveness
and it's a case of can you do this
and their answer is probably yes uh we
can do it but maybe not right
at this moment we'll do it later in the
autumn when it's the right time to do it
and it will cost you yeah and it will
cost you
so contracts are you know
an acceptable way for councils to
deliver services
but i think they are extremely difficult
to
monitor um and require um
an awful lot more management than an
in-house service yeah
um so that would be the point that i
would make anyway and the management
issues would they be those of somebody
else
not ourselves councillor osborne and
then councillor mayberry
um yeah thank you alistair um my comment
really is on
on on fly tipping um in sudbury
uh we've had ida verdi actually picking
up
uh stuff that's been dumped outside
certain houses
and certain developments which are um
baba um owned
uh and i would just like to ask uh
cassif do we make i mean there is a
chance to collect
sofas and things like that but we don't
seem to be
actually getting any money you know fly
tipping
is is a problem no doubt about that
but are we getting any uh response from
who is actually tipping this
when you know damn well that some of
these places
have could have only been responsible
for it
thank you cass do you have anything to
add to that or say to that
yeah thank you council osborne so um the
fly tipping legislation is
is very specific and you have to find
evidence at the fly tip site
that clearly shows a name or address
that could you could use as evidence to
prove that the perpetrator
unfortunately as you just mentioned you
quite often
can make a reasonable assumption of
where it came from
but unless the evidence is there for
officers to photograph at that point um
then enforcement cannot take place what
i will say is whenever
we find evidence we will always enforce
and actually um i don't have the numbers
to hand but can find them to you
but we do have um a 100
track rate for those that we have had
evidence for to
have fines paid or win prosecutions for
so we always make sure we will pursue
when we have full evidence
legality of actually prosecuting anybody
for fly tipping
however um nine times out of ten
and particularly around the areas that
uh
people are moving into and moving out of
in our social housing
unfortunately these just get tipped
outside
all i can say is that our contractor
has dealt with that but obviously we've
had to come through baba
to actually ask them to do it which
they've done
uh probably not as quick as as we would
like ex
but they have done it so what the art
the question is
would you will you be able to actually
keep that uh
fly tipping situation in hand if it is
in-house
which i am a supporter of thank you yeah
so i think we would have a very
responsive action to to floss tipping on
housing
i think what we could also uh look in
development of that is if it is on our
housing sites
um it is perfectly within our power to
let a drop
around the area to talk to residents
about
um ensuring they help us uh so quite
often
you know people you know whether it's
fly tipping sometimes it's dog fouling
and littering
people can often give us some
intelligence around that issue
and then we could send officers to watch
in those areas so
there's lots of things that we can do
around this to try and to try and make
it better so whether that's a
letter dropping to discourage it to say
that we know what's going on or by
working with the community to try and
get a bit more intelligence for
officers to observe the offences it's uh
interesting to note that members will be
hearing a report from about planning
enforcement and development
in that the enforcement of planning
conditions
not particularly construction management
plans which may have a bearing on this
and you'll be getting that very shortly
in the next couple of months and it may
have a bearing
on this particular point the other thing
is it's possible sometimes
that's not always possible to maintain a
relationship with the developers during
the build-out phase
um and point out that it's in their
interests not to
how can i put this annoy people
councillor mavery then councillor
mclaren
thank you thank you mr chairman um i've
just got
two points here um i do remember a
very substantial um fine and
um imprisonment for uh one particular
fly
tipper um and also to for councillor
osborne it
helps him that um sometimes neighbours
have photographic or
or a camera evidence uh to help with
some of this fly tipping um
the other point i would like to make for
and i'm talking about option two here if
um cabinet in the future is minded
to accept it is to remember that
if we take all this in-house um and i do
have some reservations about
um will both
of the sovereign councils have their own
um allotted time for
for the work that needs to be done um
and we do have
differences for example baber has more
um play equipment
than um than mid suffolk
it's just to remember that whatever
happens it's only as good as its
leadership
and that is going to be paramount in
whatever happens
in the future can i ask cassandra
clements as the assistant director
if an appointment has been made for a
new head of public realm service
you certainly can and he's potentially
watching as we speak
um so we have successfully recruited
just recently
uh a gentleman called will birchnall
and due to be starting on the 1st of
october
and and previously worked with the
national trust
okay i think that's an interesting point
and i thought it was what good time to
raise it
uh i have councillor mclaren and then
we'll see if we
are ready to draw a conclusion to debate
or with whether we wish to continue
council mclaren
thank you chair i'd just like to make a
comment to cassandra actually
public realm in my bit of the world does
not have a high profile
and i think we would welcome that um
not just uh because there is a subco
contractor doing the work but i think as
a department
i would like to see a bit more
interaction between my residents and the
public realm department and i would
certainly be going for the in-house
option
um had a choice thank you
as as a neighbouring in the neighboring
ward i have to say that it is very true
that the shotley peninsula
being at the extreme end of the district
and with its own unique problems beaches
were referred to after all
we have what passes the coastline for
baber
um and that brings its own problems as
has been referred to
uh so yeah good point before we go any
further i think we've looked at
uh the current situation at baber the
current situation at mid suffolk and
that affects options one two three
one area we haven't discussed is the
fourth option the latko
which i think is local authority trading
company is that the correct
yeah i got one right i love acronyms so
anybody got any thoughts on the lat co
options
these are of course largely contained in
detail within the confidential section
but if we can discuss the principle of
latko i think it would be useful
say we've done our job properly and gone
through it i note in the report
sorry to carry on that latko always
remains an option for the future
regardless of the first three options um
i wonder if members have any thoughts on
that section of the report
in general without specifically going
into a closed session
councillor wellam councilman mabry
councillor scarf
we'll work from there councillor wellam
thank you chair i mean just very very
quickly i see that latco
is worth looking at in the future but
if you were gonna go there you wouldn't
start where we are now the point
i think that's possibly true councillor
mayberry
now your microphone's off counselor
mayberry sorry i must have just
accidentally knocked it off
thank you thank you mr chairman um i
would like
like to say that i am not against
um latco at all the my only reservation
is um the in my area which is
around sudbury um i'm the love one of
the lavender ward members
is the fact that the sudbury wardens
actually do an
awful lot of work in some of the
villages
and would we be vying for competition um
there would we be vying for contracts
would we be
competition for one another uh would it
work out that's my only reservation
actually i think cass that's referred to
in the report the possibility in doing
that and following this piece of work i
would like to actively pursue that with
them
and i think the reason the
recommendation isn't around
do we therefore look at the the in-house
option where we still have the ability
to contract services on behalf of town
and paris councils where they want to
so there is still a limit as long as we
don't cross a threshold we still have
the ability to make income
just not in the same way as a latke
would and again the report does indicate
that there's less if i'm correct the
report indicates that there is
quite a lot of potential competition and
not a terribly large market
uh those do not not i think there's an
old adage that we
learned to walk before we obvious in a
couple of years time down the route that
now would be for us to consider uh
forming a
a local association trading company um
now is not the time we we we've
undergone some changes within public
realm
and uh we're under gonna i'm sure
undergo a lot more
let's get the team and the management
team um
implementing the new system across the
two districts if that's the option
and i'm certainly in favor of option two
and then consider latko at a later date
because i think it will
it will become obvious that that might
be a possibility in the future at the
right time and
and then i think would be the time to
consider it we have an
existing instruct structure in place and
we only have one year
to either set up a new contract or a
latko and that year
a year might not be enough in fact i
suggest strongly a year would
not be enough and i think the report
implies that directly
councillor osborne
uh you're a microphone's officer okay
yeah thank you uh
alastair yeah um yeah i have just um i
agree with council
well a man councillor scarf actually i
i think uh this is not the time to be
discussing that one
and as council well i'm pointed out it's
not the
and not the time to do it at
present but uh could be considered at
later dates which
unfortunately can be done i have one
question about the business case for
option two which i'll bring into the
confidential area
okay thank you okay i think at this
point we've gone through everything we
can
in terms of the public report i know
there are specific questions that
members wish to ask
for ask about in part two
although i can see a consensus forming i
think for completeness we must
have a part two so i need a proposer
for us to go into part two if i can just
find the correct wording
on my crib sheet
is that if we're not ready to make
recommendations on the basis of what
we've heard so far
we would go to a okay where is it
to consider a resolution to exclude the
public which terms
includes the press i apologize for this
but it is necessary
to consider whether pursuant to part one
of schedule 12a of the local government
act
1972 the public should be excluded from
the meeting for the business specified
below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this or these items it is
likely
they would be disclosure to them of
exempt information
as indicated against each item the
author
of the report considered or proposed
considers
to be considered in part two of the
agenda is satisfied that the public
interest in maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
do i have a proposal for that motion
yeah i will so propose
okay we don't all rush at once
uh i have councillor osborne's hand
raised and i have councillor
matheson's hand raised council ross what
are you happy to propose
yes yes and councillor matheson are you
happy to second
yes thank you thanks great uh so now we
go to the electronic voting system to be
found on modern gov
any member that has not got access to
that will be given an opportunity to
vote
do i first of all hear that everybody's
happy to do that
yes fine i don't think we need to do
recorded vote at this point because it
went very smoothly last time
so should we now be on the available on
the voting button
um no that's not quite up yet
i'm going to close mine down and reopen
it
okay henriette do we have that ready i i
have started the vote chair
um oh i'm sorry i don't seem to have it
on my sheet it says to confirm the
minutes that was carried
down the page i apologize this is a
terrible piece of chairmanship isn't it
can't even run his own
screens so resolution to exclude the
public
in progress for against abstain
of interests have we got it all in place
everybody
highlighted in blue
found it now
if anybody does have any difficulty we
are still capable of taking a
a recorded vote uh from that councillor
if they wish to
just take a roll call wrote if yeah
exactly well we'll see how we
we would like to make this system work
and it's been you know a lot of work
a lot of work time has gone into making
it available and
let's see if we can make it work so
are we there yet i'm still missing
three members to vote please and one of
them is me because
i can't ah yeah
you've got to go down the page yeah i've
found it
councilor mabry how are you progressing
councilor mayberry
uh have you been able to vote
using modern gov
we have now a completed vote chair thank
you very much
apologies to everybody that was a little
bit more difficult than we thought
because we haven't done a second vote on
the same page before
first time we are we are after all
testing this system out
um we're basically experimenting for the
whole council
so uh those vote um notes has been
carried
yes chair we did say at the start of the
meeting we were going to
have a recorded vote as well as
a um
[Music]
do we have a result that says indicates
whether we need to do a recorded vote
henriette well we have
ten members four out of ten members so i
presume that those
characters but he voted in favor so that
is all that needs to be recorded
i mean i i can i can understand that's
just at the start of the meeting we said
that we were
do a recorded vote are we going to use
this as a test
so all those people who voted voted in
fact we've dealt with this yeah
just whole chair i just need to make
sure that we are off
thank you and welcome back to members of
the public
the committee have finished their
discussion of the closed session
matters that involve matters of
confidentiality
and we are now able to bring this
part of the meeting to this paper on the
future delivery model the public realm
to a question of recommendations now you
will note
in the report that the recommendations
listed
are that weber cabinet take a decision
on the future delivery model for public
realm
based on the recommendation and
information presented within this report
well they're going to do that anyway
because that's what's on their agenda
the mid-suffolk cabinet confirmed that
they wish to continue with an in-house
delivery model
so those recommendations aren't really
directly applicable to ourselves
we are able to form our own
recommendations do i have a proposal for
any recommendation councillor wellam
thank you chair um
i i scribbled down something along the
lines of
that we thank the assistant director and
the consultants for the detailed reports
we recommend the option to be pursued
for delivery of the public realm service
in the two districts
that further work be undertaken in
respect of developing kpis and contract
management
including internal recharging and closer
monitoring of the contract works
in works of id verdi
okay that discusses i'm afraid the id
verdi thing should probably not be
included since that does not actually on
the
papers we're reporting that contract
will come to an end anyway
and it isn't actually covered by the
scope of the report
so with the exception of that piece i'd
be happy to second that
and he would that make sense to you
councillor welum
well if we could say closer monitoring
of of
um work currently being undertaken or
something
i believe that's reasonable and fair i
think it's just probably not good
practice to
name names in these instances just
just to keep it as it is um effectively
we are can you repeat that and see if
henriette can make sure she has that
clearly as i say i'm i'm prepared to
second that
general principle that we're endorsing
if i would use the word we would endorse
option two
a joint in-house service would it help
if i
read the whole lot yes yes please um
we thank the assistant director and
consultants for the detailed reports
we recommend that the option to be
pursued for delivery of the public realm
service in the two districts
that further work be undertaken in
respect of developing kpis
and contract management i think those
two should be split into separate
resolutions
separate recommendations one is that we
should go
to option we would endorse option two
as the preferred recommendation
again they're just trying to use the
wording that's contained within the
report
and that two you cover the second point
to the point of the report
of a report there if you follow me i
think that makes the decision
clearer and separate separates two
separate decisions absolutely agree
yes are you happy with that counselor
william and can you make that work henry
yes can you read what you have henriette
no okay well we i would i would suggest
that
we endorse option two as the preferred
recommendation for cabinet to consider
just trying to keep the language
consistent yes sorry chair i'm just
scribbling like mad here i understand
so endorse option two as recommended
obviously dress it up overview and
scrutiny from joint
councils and then that was the first
part and then the second part was
that the um
second recommendation would be keith
that further work be undertaken in
respect of developing kpis
and contract management
and a third rec and a third
recommendation that options should be
kept and again i'm reading this again
from what members have said and i hope
that this is something that all members
can get behind
that the further option um of a latko
continue to be kept as a future option
for both councils to consider
in other words we're not closing any
doors here
i believe that that should be the third
recommendation
great okay are you happy with that
councillor willem as the proposer
yes i think so yeah
okay is everybody clear on those three
recommendations
fine okay so now we'll do a roll call
vote
on the recommendation proposed and
seconded of three recommendations we'll
do them in
one go or three chair are we
are we are we curtailing a question of
any additional recommendations to those
three
by this vote unless somebody wishes to
propose an amended
recommendation well i i'm quite happy
with the three
the three that we had before us um i did
feel that
now that we've taken the trouble to put
in the work on on
all this there's two things that stand
out to me
that we should just be saying to to the
cabinets the first one is
is that the um the work audit work on
this
should be a very high priority and the
other thing which hasn't been discussed
much
but i a scrutiny committee a long years
ago
when i was on it previously this
business of the
tree inspection is incredibly important
um it puts the council at huge risk um
if we're not on top of it and the audit
committee back in the day
twice hold the relevant manager back in
front of them
um because their recommendations from
from scrutiny had not been carried out
and um so i i've got a particular
concern that i haven't had a chance to
express yet
oh i understand your concern but i don't
think it's addressed in the point that
this report addresses the four
options and we are actually looking at
the four options
rather than specific examples of poor
performance
anywhere else that would include the
audit question
now i think your audit question has
largely been asked
i mean i answered rather um it's been
asked and answered
and that could be brought up elsewhere
but i don't think it falls within the
scope of the report
that we're considering or the report
that we'll be going to cabinet that's an
important character jericho
do you feel they should know it really
well they can read the minutes of this
meeting but i i just believe that we
have to deal with the report in front of
us and not
make it into something that isn't
covering now we have lots of hands
raised here
so let's go to councillor mclaren i
think was amongst the first then
councillor hattingham then councillor
osborne and councillor wellam
councillor mclaren chair i am i'm not
quite
clear about the recommendation for the
simple reason
that baber is the one that's going to
change
the option and on the page
i think it's about three on the first
part of the report the recommendation
is that baba cabinet take a decision on
the future delivery
um yes those of course those those those
to be fair are the
recommendations prepared for a cabinet
we're overview and scrutiny
so i was proposing that suggesting that
we do not use the recommendations
but do we have to separate the two
recommendations because
mid-support doesn't have to be voted on
because they already have
an in-house provision should they be
separated
should baber be option two
and a confirmation that mit suffolk
still want to continue
with the in-house now option option two
covers both baber and mid suffolk
and i believe but i don't know okay i
just thought
i i think we we're needlessly making
mary i understand what you're saying
but i don't think it's the way we can do
it okay
is all i'm saying from a governance
point of view it doesn't seem to me that
that is clear
um let's simplify things to the point
where option two
affects both councils and in fact
enhances the service at mid-suffolk
uh we are making recommendations to
cabinet
not the cabinet making recommend no
sorry i i read the wrong thing
sorry okay that's my point so if we have
those three recommendations next i had
uh
think counselor hadingham
thanks um um i'm just a bit um fuzzy
with the middle one talking about the
kpis and everything i just don't want to
give um cass and her team extra work
where it's clearly in the report i think
it's 5
11 that says officers will ensure that
members are kept updated on progress
with
monthly joint progress updates with
portfolio holders
monthly updates the environment
programme board and quarterly updates to
both
cabinets i think that they're frankly
already doing their homework
and um and um there's no need to
complicate it and give them more work
fair point i think it's just probably
that uh keith's
recommendation was to draw attention and
stress and confirm that point
to the cabinet um the fact it's already
taking place is a bonus
um i i'm happy either way
um i don't think it does any harm
chair i think i think we're it's only
confirming what cass said she would be
doing anyway
yes okay well we could we could we could
as councillor haddington says
take it out i'd rather i'd rather keep
it in
in that case i i think we i would
probably tend towards keeping it in
even if you feel it's not entirely
necessary it lays stress
and it addresses the point to the public
that we are addressing
an existing known problem so that's fine
in my view counselor osborne
oh yeah thank you um aleister you know
can i just say that
um i think your recommendations are are
were excellent the way
you praised it and you've brought the
position out with the
uh position of where we're coming from
and what we're voting on and uh i'll go
along with
what with your recommendations thank you
well councillor
recommendation seconded by me to do this
we'll be carrying a roll call
vote um if henriette has that ready uh
the same provision to our previous vote
applies
that uh council dawson who had to leave
the meeting
and i trust that's been resolved for you
councillor dawson uh
won't be able to vote on this or these
recommendations
henriette could you uh call the roll
call please
yes uh chair i will be calling you out
in um
uh well for under each council at the
moment that's how i have it
recorded here so please answer um for
against abstain
uh councillor gould
council goes left i do apologize uh
councillor mayberry
for councilman crawl for
council mclaren
uh because mclaren you are unmuted
you're still in mute that's it no four
four
you're four councillor osborne
four councillor hattingham
four councillor madison
and that concludes the vote chair and it
is unanimous
all all in favor those recommendations
will go forward to babera cabinet
at the meeting to discuss the same paper
thank you very much members i think
you've done the subject
full justice can we thank cassandra
clements and her officers for the work
that they put into this
we also thank the consultants uh who
who've really done an excellent job and
answered all our questions so
uh colin mark that's been much
appreciated
long meeting a lot of work you've done
uh i think we've we've tried to pay due
respect to the work you've done
so thank you thank you all for your time
so now we'll go back in the agenda
to where we were before we started
looking at this paper
which is item eight on the agenda the
forthcoming decision list the members
have any comments
on that list this is for noting i should
say
chair i didn't see anything on there
that needs to be brought forward as a
scrutiny item
i agree with you
uh nobody else have any points they wish
to raise on that
fine items nine and ten
we can take these together i believe
since they are virtually identical
and these are the baber and mid suffolk
overview and scrutiny work plans
these are always works in progress and
the chairs meet every month
to make sure they continue to progress
does anybody have
any comments these again are for noting
yes chair i've got
um i've got several but um the first one
is um over the
18th of january 2021
um the two for the first two items on
there
um will have to be done separately
because
one is obviously a that's a baber
one and uh a similar mid-suffoc item on
the
uh general fund and the hra
whereas the third item on that list the
annual review of local citizens advice
that should be at a joint meeting
i agree so should we move that to
february and make
february a joint meeting i was going to
suggest rather than make the decision
now that we discuss this in the chairs
meetings
between now and then in terms of the
scheduling of witnesses
that's always been a consideration in
dealing with the outside bodies
um chair i'd understood from um
from henriette that we need to uh
confirm
something today so that it goes forward
to council but i may have got that wrong
henrietta is that correct yes uh chair
you do need to
agree the work plan today because it's
going to full council later on this
month
for um for okay
so the suggestion is that the annual
review of local citizens advice
be moved to the february meeting
and the february and february and march
and may meetings are all joint meetings
okay i think that should be
provisionally agreed
subjects of course can be entered at a
later point
um we did have um an item which seems to
have drifted off which was
progress on bringing vacant homes into
use and we were going to
we were going to put that into the
program at some point but
perhaps we can't do that today because
we don't have the advice of
of the relevant office or when that
might be ready
no we don't and we haven't had the
opportunity to discuss it
because obviously we have been dealing
with lockdown and that
has been a separate matter for vacant
properties
and will probably continue to be so so i
think in the circumstances we'd accept
that we'd
move the citizen's advice to a joint
meeting in february
that's the 22nd of february 2021
and leave the uh meetings of the 18th
around the 18th of january for the two
councils
dealing with the scrutiny of the budget
and the h and the hra
account for separate meetings that makes
sense
uh are members happy with those changes
okay that can be so done it doesn't
require a vote this is just for noting
okay and i believe henry
chair i think um
i think we just do a vote yes please
because it is going to cancel so can we
just
agree there for former's sake we'll go
for a vote uh would somebody like to
propose
that those changes well i i
i suggested them so i'm happy to propose
thank you
councillor who's allowed to second them
thank you very much councillor miller
seconding
uh right a roll call vote please do it
electronically
i think we should i think we should have
a roll call vote is quicker
when there's only so few people here
yeah let's do a roll call vote
thank you sir um councillor uh
hattingham this will be a mixed up vote
by the way council hattingham
four council madison or
council mayberry four councilman crawl
four council mclaren four
council mulan four councillor osborne
oh how's the scarf four
councilwell four and that's carriage
chan
and i believe am i right to say this
henriette that that draws the meeting to
a close
it certainly does chair thanks to all
members for a very lengthy session
and the time we spent the hour we spent
beforehand getting ready for it
and the length of time that you spent
going through the papers it's clear that
everybody had a pretty good grasp on the
subject and we went
did the job properly as i would expect
to be honest with you councillor dawson
you have your hand raised was there
something you wanted to say
i was gonna lois i was just sort of
wondering wasn't
you